In August 2017, Denver Public Schools
unveiled a new school lunch policy in a
push to end lunch shaming. There are
students who are eligible for the
federal free and reduced lunch program – set
them aside. They're not the ones we're
talking about. There are students who are
not eligible for federal free and reduced
lunch because their families can afford to
pay for lunch. What Denver said to these
families is that their children would
get lunch at school if they paid for it,
and they would get lunch if they did not.
A year later, the check came due. Debt from
unpaid lunches in the 2017-18 school
year grew more than 25 fold, to more
than $350,000, or about nine hundred unpaid
lunches a day. Now, no one wants to see
children go hungry because of their
family's financial circumstances. But
neither do we want to shift dollars from
academics to the lunch line due to
feel-good schemes that go south. The
lesson: Even the most well-meaning of
bureaucratic policies can have unintended
consequences, eroding the trust essential
to healthy schools and compassionate communities.
Is it surprising to you that
so many people seemed to take advantage of
Denver's program? And why or why not? Let
us know in your comments. Also, let us
know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.